hello and welcome to this special video
in the Simon Oxford book club I'm Simon
Oxford and I'm joined by Lily and dad
Lily's a friend of ours down is my
housemates we're all students and we're
all talking about Harry Potter and the
cursed child of the most recent book
well it's not really by JK Rowling is it
filmed so we've all read this recently
what did we think it made me angry
like I finished it and I was like
seething I enjoyed it a controversial I
know but I enjoyed it it was it's been I
should preface everything I say by
saying I absolutely I am like I'm a
tremendous bias
really will be expecting I will probably
bleep okay so so you you were made angry
my friends laughing at me because I was
reading it and like a very silent room
and occasionally I were just chatting
[Laughter]
yeah
[Laughter]
I am also diary like I was midnight
boots around I was there and like the
film's really stressed out maybe this
book just like upset me because I just
didn't it's not I know it's like a
personal thing it's just not the way I
wanted the calendar go okay so what was
the bit what was the main problem with
it yeah I think everyone's saying like
oh like it's you know it's a it's a
script you can't get like a full meaning
out of it and I'm like yeah but all I'm
left with here is the plot and the
dialogue so that is what I'm gonna judge
yeah so we should probably mention for
those of you who somehow haven't read
this yet this is a story by JK Rowling
which has been adapted into a script by
John Tiffany Jack Thorne which has been
put on in London the moment and so the
book itself isn't prose it is dialogue
and you have stage directions to so we
should also preface this by saying none
of us have seen the stage show well we
can't afford it I also actively wanted
to read the slit first because I had my
doubts about the stage show I wasn't
sure how well it would be with it being
you know so I mean magic it for one like
I think that while they can do amazing
amazing things on stage in the moment I
think that kind of conversion they would
really struggle with I mean it's
absolutely incredible
the Stacia it's got much better reviews
than the book yeah I've had friends
who've seen it and they were just like
the magic is just incredible and I was
like I'm sure it was but that is not
what I get to judge when I read it okay
so what is that what is the plot then
broad strokes what is the plot
Harry's youngest child Albus befriends
Scorpius mal Voisin obviously on the
train to Hogwarts because he feels like
he's under his father's shadow and
there's time tone is involved and they
got to shenanigans to kind of freeze it
like they get spoiling things I don't
think we should going to spoil it but
the shenanigans shenanigans
I mean this is how many years in the
future 20 it's not to nineteen because
it's nineteen years old but then it
quickly goes to when I was in school
he's 14 isn't it yes four wasn't yeah
not only for the in the style of you
know that in the lives of the characters
are there flashes forward and flashes
back but also the way the plot is
structured
there's a lot of jumping around in
timelines and time travel is notoriously
difficult to write yes that's where I
was just like I think for one thing well
I certainly don't think the plot was
perfect and I think the reason why
people were so kind of disappointed
certainly you know like everyone here
quite strong Potter fans this because it
is so distant and it feels so far away
from what we're used to with Harry
Potter
it's got yeah more mature themes for
yeah and the sense of magic is far less
I think that's wise because it's based
it's you know it's meant for stage well
there is magic and they can pull off
some tricks which you read as stage
direction and the biggest difference is
this book is just distant from the kind
of magical world that we know and also
the characters because obviously they
developed over 20 odd years the
characters are really quite different
yeah apart from wrong see I think no one
just turns up and eats the end of the
series he had so much more depth to him
by the end of the seventh book then
turning up for occasional punch lines
and to eat okay give me an example like
the final book does everything he did
like gave him like background he was so
much more to play three dimension I
think yeah arguably of the main trio he
has the strongest character arc in the
face and how much he changes bearing in
mind he was the one in who left to come
back so they're already you have massive
change I do think that they under played
him in the book but he's and he's the
most one-dimensional in this I mean both
are near on a very one-dimensional
mining is your career woman who doesn't
like she's well she does respond to much
much things in kind where the whole
marriage thing yeah I don't know I
thought I didn't for me it was partly
their careers as well as not where I
would have thought any of it would have
went I don't think her money would be
ministered ministerís she like I can't
see how chaining herself to an
organization that she resented and hated
so many years and that she thought was
corrupt that that organisation that she
hated for so many years had changed a
great deal when Kingsley Shacklebolt
became there was a change there and I
think also we should remember too that
while it is a Harry Potter book and you
immediately think of the famous three
it's called the check the curse of child
it's not about focus on the next
generation so I think in a way you're
always going to almost from the very
beginning your arm is going to feel like
those characters yes I think for me like
they're they're kind of where they went
from it always felt like they were
taking the characters from the films and
not the books and taking them especially
like Ginny was like the person who made
me think of that because like we took a
free Harry like I was like oh like Ginny
Weasley is not like this person like she
is a badass quit playing like she didn't
turn up reporting Quidditch for The
Daily Prophet would do that like like
have to see that film did it was well
that's enough very interesting sort of
point overall and that this isn't this
isn't just the sequel to of the books
it's the sequel to the film's yeah and
you know it's trying to draw on to I
guess very similar but different
yeah yeah yeah it's interesting that
we've only talked about the kids I
thought Scorpius was a really cool
character like I was glad that he I hear
that I felt was the most interesting
yeah from his from his introduction yeah
I'm already know after I don't know
maybe 20 lines of dialogue you like this
guy I think a lot of that is to do with
his mouth voice son and he's so
different from my voice yeah you can
kind of relate to him and both I think
too you understand where Albus is coming
from to having a having a dad like he
does I feel like he wasn't written that
strongly no
saying but again like all we have is
dialogue which I think was Paul yes
because he's been using the show he's
like a grumpy teenager and like mmm it
kind of remind me of like book 5 Harry
like you know any Harry like whiny
Harry's but like when Harry like you
totally understand and you empathizing
like oh you just feel so bad for him
Albus I was just like get over it like
sorry but I don't know I certainly no
point did I feel that he was I think I
would I would probably not as strong or
as deep as Scorpius because I wouldn't
be surprised if Scorpius actually has
more dialogue yeah from one of the one
of the flashbacks in time yeah and he
yeah interesting too because they're
kind of the duo that they form
Albus usually kind of leads away and
Scorpius is the one kind of cracking the
lines of being like oh not this again
yeah and so he was like the Brawn of the
- yeah when she's tricked the power
dynamic at least that it wasn't just
another trio yeah yes history though I
do think it was contrived like yeah
that's the biggest problem I have with
this yeah why did it need to exist yeah
I mean it's not like she needs the money
for one thing I don't believe this you
write this for money produced exactly
made people happy who read it like I
mean do you think this was because she
had Marta sztyc itch scratch she wants
it as a challenge
I think she's alright time travel I
think she just wanted to do it and I
think that's fine and and and if she's
going she's going into it with that you
know she obviously she cares so much and
she hasn't done a George Lucas she
hasn't had so much about a franchise
that she's absolutely ruined it I well
people would be disappointed I don't
think people will be saying well I would
be happier if it never had existed oh I
don't know I think I'd be really yeah
because I had my own like ideas of where
it was all gonna go yeah I mean I like
they were just obliterated in this kind
of upsets me because I think I should
have been said so far though certainly
in regards to the kind of the trio yeah
and where they have gone the Canon
storyline existed before this book was
written there's a mess
so much that is canonized through either
Pottermore or wiki's that have been
confirmed as their their future life yes
so I don't I don't think I don't think
the issues there I think if I feel like
I've wasted time Rio that I want to
unreal like did you it was a bit mad did
any of them did either of you cry
reading this no well you're you're like
a leaky faucet I think the thing that
most emotionally affected me was when
one of the time Turner's go back and
come back and it was Voldemort day that
reality thing I found that quite
affecting the opening of Snape yeah I
think I've really enjoyed that it was
dangerous because it is totally changing
a character right that we all have in
our heads granted it's a different we
have us TV on and we have photos of our
friends coming up sort of from our
albums and a wonderful picture we're not
showing you that because he will kill us
Peter it's you really got me was finally
seeing when done but when Harry is
speaking to the portrait of Dumbledore
finally gets to voice and you really do
and he properly hammers ignore he
completely kind of stares it down and he
gets angry properly and not kind of
child angry this is a great with kids
and you see Dumbledore it's written in
as Dumbledore welling up and crying and
saying like I you know and finally kind
of admitting his fault yeah read and
really I thought was important and I'm
so glad that she did because she could
you know she could have kept it all kind
of mysterious and and and him being that
character that you never really
understand I never questioned really
yeah he's always this powerful figure
and I think the point you actually there
about having that already being cannon
through Pottermore and through wiki's is
interesting in that maybe this is one of
the very first sort of postmodern books
that's how to deal with that yeah you
know it has to fit in with all this
other stuff it's gonna I'm not ready at
it it's almost like I'm
if well yeah I actually think that it
would have been better off if it had a
Star Wars Episode 7 because there was a
pre-existing Canon for that yeah I would
have paid good money to have a book
about orders like that would have
brought me so much joy
say but even to say that whether it has
managed it or it hasn't managed it
implies that when you finish reading
this book you will have an opinion
opinion of one or the other of a kind of
you know it totally satisfied me or
didn't satisfy me at all it served the
previous books yes it did or no it
didn't I don't think it if you're kind
of looking at it like that
you're not doing the book justice
because there is so much I think it's
very much a scale and I think while
people can you know fervently disagree
and say no I really really didn't enjoy
it and then you get you know people who
are almost blinded I think by I am
slightly by my love of the franchise you
know I've been waiting so long to hear
more we every now and then we hear
things through those other canonized
websites or kind of mediums where she
writes small short stories but for a lot
of people certainly me it was just so
great to go back into that world again
granted it was different but it was
still going back what do you think she
should have changed what could be done
to salvage this book write a new breed I
think given how people talk about the
books and the films one of I think gets
the most flak is Azkaban the film the
guest that gets the most praise it's
definitely the best film it's also my
least favorite book and I think it is
the time trouble I just I can't get over
like I feel the touch of him this is
better than in Azkaban oh yeah she she
would have heard I mean I know she
wishes
JK will not be oblivious to the fact
that a lot of people really didn't enjoy
that and I think not only is it brave
for her to even consider you're writing
a new piece of new piece for the
franchise but for the main plot device
to be time-travel does this to quell the
haters then I don't think not to quell
them no but to to kind of say okay well
let me try again
let's give it let's give it another go
and certainly for me while
there are parts and the stories where
you in those multiple kind of what would
you call the timelines I guess yeah
where they go back to there are certain
kind of twists in plot you think all
that's a little bit reach you know how
lucky yeah yeah I think I think it could
have been you know people are saying how
long is the play is like like four hours
yeah like people say it could have just
been so much shorter and I feel the same
with this like it could like so much but
this was this felt too short to me oh we
see I was just like I was like stop
giving me cameos of the characters like
stop giving me like like about five
hours long read yeah yeah I think with
it it feels short because we are missing
so yeah of the full experience no no if
you if you really really want to form a
good and honest opinion and if you're if
you've read the book and you think well
you know I enjoyed it but there are
other parts that I'm not quite sure you
have to see the stage show because it
will it will change it but do you not
think the stage show is just smoke and
mirrors of what is that like the core is
the plot in the dialogue and that's what
we get here everything that everyone is
saying is amazing on stage is just yeah
it's the acting and the people and like
the special effects which is not what I
mean when you read Shakespeare in script
form it still is just as engaging yeah
it's true you know oh yes the stage adds
value to it yeah that makes understand
it more but bones of it it makes you
understand it more like I think that you
you you cannot completely commit
yourself with your opinion just to the
book especially if it's a really strong
one and totally rule out the stage when
it's written for the stage I mean I
don't think it you know might not you
might say it and you can your opinion
may remain the same but just having that
experience and exposing yourself to the
medium that it's meant to be experienced
in you know it's not I think we're very
lucky that she even released a play
script she could have very simply gone
notice when I keep it on the stage I got
so angry with JK Rowling when she was
like oh yeah I've done it so like to get
people to the theater who like wouldn't
go and like people from my background I
was like tickets are like hundred pounds
yeah this is not
like I mean I still would love to see
the show oh yeah I'd love to do it
official and I do think I mean certainly
some of the stage directions you mean
you're like shrinking the stage
reversing time that's not how it works
okay well there are pages and pages when
you see it advertised
it's just block text paragraphs and
paragraphs of five stars
yeah I think it's a spectacle
transformations on stage yeah well
that's a whole another thing well well
it is a book club the importance of it
being a staged piece and the work
it's that work has been done and their
steps forward that it is taking for
theater you know it's caused some
serious ripples and what has been
achieved I think many other kind of
directors playwrights are going to are
going to want to see it and think oh
well you know what we can do these kind
of things you know God knows how they
have and I don't want to know because
again the magic now it's a bit like a
Hamilton did for musical you know if
that reinvigorated the genre especially
historical musicals so much you know I
thought the villain is the female but
then I won't spoil there's like one
female new character you can almost have
read this and the time you've watched
this yeah I thought this she was totally
on yeah I also just don't think oh we
just can I just go for the spoiler by
this okay from this point onwards we
haven't seen and I haven't read it
spoilers Baltimore would not want a
child it also I don't like the idea of
homing like sexual organ I also don't
like that dare him coming back like that
seems to be supremely lazy yeah like oh
this that shadowy threat from before
like you might return yeah I mean I'm
right if you're gonna have an antagonist
there's so many loose threads beneath so
many things she could have gone like so
many routes you get the werewolf free
yeah instead like you could have mean
Bane and the the centaurs
I also was just like I thought that
whole bit was bit like we went see Bane
okay add is nothing apart from like
probably something spooky on stage I
think
with in regards to Voldemort coming back
if she did ever and she's you know she
has come out and said to the media that
she this will be the end now but that's
what she said at the end of the seventh
book if she did ever write a story where
there was a kind of drastic change as to
the antagonist not being Baltimore and
it being totally different and going
down a completely different route which
I kind of I think I wouldn't I wouldn't
say I don't want anymore
you know if she comes out with more more
and more I'm gonna take it you know I'm
gonna consume it but I don't think it
would be Harry Potter and I think the
titles would change I think that it
wouldn't it would be totally dissed it
wouldn't be Harry Potter and the you
know because then he's in the joint live
news amanda is doing in the film well
exactly
yeah I'm not sold on really worried
about it yeah really hope it's going to
be good I mean Colin Firth in it I'm
excited for I felt like this on the
territory of Farrell yes although I mean
if he wasn't like the aesthetic of going
to twenties America isn't it I'm so
excited for it doesn't have to be as
good as a Harry Potter books it's in the
same universe but and it doesn't have
any threads that need it doesn't lead up
it can just be on its own really good it
can just be like a fun film in its own
right it doesn't have to be amazing I'm
hopeful at the end of the day the
universe she's made it still amazing yes
I just feel that this story perhaps
wasn't the right one to tell I think
yeah the thing that I think everyone
will agree with even if you do if you
loved it or you hated the book is that
the ending of the seventh book was an
ending yeah kind of like you've properly
read the end and you were like yeah your
life where you feel like there's not
gonna be any more of these because it is
definitely she kept writing all those
great I mean there was a I can't
remember when it would have been I think
maybe a couple of months ago they wrote
there was a really gorgeous short story
about and that's awesome I thought that
was really really nice and and again
like with fantastic beasts and where to
find them you can you can consume that
and it's totally on its own and it's set
up from everything else and that's fine
I've read all the stuff that she's put
out for
they're fantastic beasts kind of
universe is it I forget the name of the
[Music]
[Music]
problem with the fact that like JK
Rowling coolly understands nothing about
American culture if she takes a hold of
America I'd be really interested to see
how they pull the film off I'm really
excited for it and I think that since
the last book the advances that have
been made in film amazing because I
think if you're a lover of the books
you're almost psyching yourself up to be
slightly disappointed but also they're
very violent films the big will be yeah
because so much of the bits in the book
that I love are not really yes was it
if the Phoenix were this Harry and show
go into that it would be such a funny
thing it wasn't done and I understand
that because you know you've got a
certain amount of time and you've really
got to consolidate what is Voldemort can
can fly and him and Harry are having
like a wrestling match and he can
control chains and stuff this isn't just
Harry Potter though I mean like you
could see I mean ruin a whole branch I
mean a reference of this is a really bad
kind of a hobbit it's a great book and
love the book but you do get scenes in
it like the storm Giants scene yeah
which is meant to be there looking out
of a cave and they hate God is that
thunder no it's Giants then you move on
and then the film you have like a
ten-minute sequence of just
Lassa sea Colossus is fighting and with
any book to film conversion they're
going to be scenes are added purely for
spectacle because not everybody is going
to be consuming the film the thing that
you know you need to appease everyone
yes
well also the Hobbit films are terrible
anyway we're off peace so we've been
talking about this for ages okay right
quick rating at 10 go Liddy six that's
generous
yeah five five six point eight oh wait
no on average that means we're about
five wait I won't change mine no so it's
about a five out of ten who should read
it anyone who is interested in wanting
to have an opinion if you have ever been
exposed to the franchise be in the films
or the books or if you haven't seen any
of them and you've just you kind of
jumped in on the whole Pottermore bad
before it is what it is now you know
there was one a couple of years ago
where you could be sorted and you did
all those things and there was like a
point based system even if it's just
that if you've been exposed to the
franchise I think it certainly wouldn't
do any harm I don't know that I
definitely I think people who shouldn't
watch it people who've seen the films
I'm not read any of the books like yes
that's your first Harry Potter book it's
not your first choice a book because
it's not yeah yes so distant from all
the other books it's wrong to consider
it it's wrong to call it oh it's the
eighth book it's perhaps it should be
called the cursed child and Harry Potter
yeah would that make more sense
considering that onus is very much all
you could just be to try and fit it into
the mold of all the previous books with
her with having Harry Potter and the I
think is setting a reader up oh it's not
the other books having said that I think
it's worth the read it is I'm not sure
it is like that to be honest I mean if
you can borrow a copy I wouldn't
necessarily say
thank you for joining us if you enjoyed
this hope you'll get to do some more
discussions like this in the future I
might wrote down in to do book clubs in
the future anyway you're not you're off
to uni but thanks for joining us um if
you agree or disagree with us want to
hear about it in the comments down below
and fight us and we'll see you next time
[Music]